amelia is in boston hi amelia how are
you
hi dave hi ken i'm well thank you for
taking my call sure
what's up um so i'm calling in today to
get some guidance
on getting on the same page with money
uh as my grandmother
actually um she has given me a very
generous gift
um and put it in a trust for me of a
hundred thousand dollars
earmarked for tuition and for a purchase
of my first home when the time comes
so we've taken chunks out of that over
the years for tuition and there's about
75 000
left i personally outside of that i'm
just about to finish baby step three so
i'm looking to purchase my first home in
the next
one to three years now the question here
that's causing some
uh contention and disagreement is that
that money is all invested in the market
mostly in
index funds right now and with me
wanting to use it in the relatively
short term
my position is that we should take it
out and have it in cash well my
grandmother's position
is you know it's done well it's earned
great returns over the last several
years
why would we not want to continue that
so i'm working on guidance as to
how to have that conversation um and do
what i believe is the right thing with
this money while
you know still being extremely grateful
for the gift
she gave you the money and she put it in
trust and she's managing the trust
correct she's a bit of a control freak
so i i think with money it's mainly a
position of experience you know i'm
22 she's 74. so uh
she's got a lifetime of experience and
it does seem to me a bit controlling you
know i'm
a natural saver and financially
responsible
you're in control and the money was
given to you by a house
and you can't take it out and buy a
house with it
right i don't understand
yeah uh i mean that's that's the point
that i'm stuck
at is how to have that conversation um
so are you when are you gonna buy a
house um
probably in two or three years why two
or three years
uh because i'm not sure that i want to
stay in this area long term
so you know i'm waiting to get a little
confidence there before i make the
financial commitment to a house
okay well this is more of an issue of uh
you know puppet master than it is actual
financial advice
right yeah and so that you know you just
got to decide which hill you want to die
on um as far as the you know her advice
goes it's not the end of the world okay
let's say that those
index funds went down 10
during that three years which would be
one of the worst three year periods in
the stock market's history
sure then you would have lost seven
thousand dollars
right yeah it's it's not end of the
world either way yeah and and so
and if it goes up 10 during that time
you would have made seven thousand
dollars
so you know you your
fear of this money not of this money
being in the market
is not substance shouldn't be
substantial because the actual dollar
figures aren't going to be substantial
her wanting to take advantage of the
market is almost laughable
because it's also going to be about
seven thousand dollars
right it's a philosophical thing
you know is really all it comes down to
so
you know and that reveals
that you guys are both being drama
queens about this
yeah that's fair to say um yeah it's
you know it's not a big deal either way
but it's difficult to have the
conversation yeah it's just like
it's a control conversation right it's a
puppet master conversation and
you know so like i don't know if this
woman is actually going to release this
money when you're ready to buy a house i
can't tell
yeah i'm sometimes worried about that um
because she's actually taken out the the
growth that's already come onto the
account over time
so yeah yeah oh she took it out and used
it herself yeah
wow yes which i mean the original
balance is still there so that was her
call but wow yeah that was not something
i was about to say just a little strange
so here's what i'm gonna do i'm just go
about the business of building up your
own down payment
and then if that money's there and she
wants to give it to you fine if not just
tell her to keep
it yeah absolutely that's fair enough
that's pretty much the plan uh either
way yeah because i i don't think you're
going to win this argument one more
thing
okay she because her the problem with
her
actually letting you buy a house with
the 75 000 is that's the last
conversation
she has where she gets to tell you what
to do and she really likes telling you
what to do
so i okay so i gotta ask you this i'm
surprised at your answer
i was a little surprised is it great i
mean it's dead on but i thought
don't you just die on that hill with
grandma you told me this is what it was
for
i'm not going to fight with you and ruin
our relationship but that's what that's
it
yeah i mean because listen you can hear
what's happening with this lady
and there is no winning the argument
with this woman 100 agree
okay so why have the argument because
you're not going to win it right you're
either going to sever the relationship
over seven thousand dollars and the
money's not the thing
it's the control mm-hmm and um so
and then the other side of that is if
i'm making a gift if i'm the grandma
okay i've often said on here you're
gonna get my money you're gonna get my
instruction
okay but i have never given someone a
gift
and then managed it right
that's not a gift yeah that's that's
controlling so that's you know but i
i would say i'm not going to give you
this gift if you're not doing these
things
but once it's given you need to take
your hand off of it i agree
and uh you're saying don't even try to
have the conversation and go hey listen
i don't want to fight i don't want this
to be good
you say grandma i love you and thank you
for the money and i hope it's there
if you still want to do it when we get
ready to buy a house that'll be fine
because we're going to go ahead and
start building up our own down payment
i know you'll be proud of us when we did
that i love you thank you and just keep
moving
because what it does just takes all of
her power away and she really is a lot
about power
that's true what happens when gra if
grandma dies before this
i suspect the trust has terms that leave
it too that would beneficiary of the
truth
is amelia okay that okay that's good i
needed to process through that because
sometimes it's like principal let's have
the conversation and i think you're
right
now as i process what you said it's like
i'm channeling my inner john deloney
just
just tell them you love them and keep
going i think you're right i was
wondering though i was like okay trying
to be nicer deloney's
inspired me to be nicer he's very nice
he is a nice very in touch with his
feelings and ours
he's in touch with everyone's feet he
really is he really is that's good and
he has a lot of feelings